Podcast you dumb [ __ ] speaking of which
this is this is a new part of the
podcast it's is that Bill's dumb Bill's
dumb quote of the week I had a bunch of
people correct me on something that I've
been saying for years I used the
expression I said for all extensive
purposes and somebody wrote for all
extensive purposes it's not you don't
say it that way and you don't say it the
way most other people say all intensive
purposes it's actually for all intents
and purposes you like that most people
say for all intensive purposes when they
[ __ ] it up bill burr took it to a whole
new level of stupid and said for all
extensive purposes I do that all the
time